I always felt forster was overrated
frankly.
Um,
to take an obvious example.
Never really got it.
Uh,
when people go on and on about Graham
Greene,
especially his important books like end
of the affair,
I get puzzled by.
Shouldn't be.
I mean there's nothing wrong with green
and there's nothing wrong with forrester
either.
I just feel like
what's all the fuss about?
What is all the fuss about?
Damned if I know frankly.
Um,
I think there is a,
there are,
there must be American writers.
Well Dave Wallace I think is one of them
and probably George Saunders is another
who I don't think the Brits get it all.
I think they're just like,
why do people or why this is so.
This is so purell oil.
It's so easy.
It's like I don't know what they're
thinking or this is so bratty.
It's so annoying.
Or it's so broad or whatever they're
saying.
I think there's a category of American
fiction that just doesn't cross the
ocean so well.
And I think that I'm talking about a
strain of British fiction writing
a not inconsiderable strain of British
fiction writing that I don't that some
people
to some people,
this is what a novel is.
It's an enforced or novel or a Graham
Greene novel.
They're living practitioners in England
producing novels that also today seem
like,
well,
this is what a real novelist is and this
is what a real novel is.
Um,
and for some of us in America,
you're just like say that's not even a
novelist hardly.
That's sort of a,
it's,
it's an,
it's an a near perfect replica of a
novel.
It's,
um,
so it's a taste thing.
Uh,
I think there's a kind of well made
product that,
that forster pioneered and represents,
um,
that engendered a great many very well
made novels in England in the 20th
century that either think is like what
an novel should be,
or else you just throw up your hand.